foreign
[Music]
topic and it is something which you will
have to master bit by bit however there
are many basic projects that you can
take up as a beginner in AI there are
plenty of resources online but sometimes
as a beginner in AI doesn't know where
to start this video will help you to get
interesting ideas on projects in AI hey
everyone welcome to Simply learn before
moving on please make sure you subscribe
to Simply learns YouTube channel and
press the Bell icon to never miss any
updates let us Define artificial
intelligence First artificial
intelligence is a technique of turning a
computer-based robot to work and act
like humans now let me list out
important AI projects for you face
detection system it is a form of
biometric recognition a method for
identifying or confirming someone's
identity by glancing at their face is
called facial recognition people can be
added identified by securing a match on
facial ID using this technique real-time
visuals videos and photos can be the
sources to run face detection this
technology is mostly employed in
security and law enforcement opencv is
the best technology to create it a
python package called opencv is made
specifically to address computer vision
jobs computer vision is a process used
in the processing of images by computers
it is concerned with the in-depth
comprehension of digital photos or films
it is necessary to automate operations
that can be performed by human visual
systems therefore a computer should be
able to identify items like a statue or
a Lamppost or even the face of a human
being second one is chatbot it is the
best idea if you have chosen chatbot as
your project topic this will make your
resume more attractive in case you are
looking for a job I Oracle survey
suggests that 80 of the businesses uses
chatbot you can use Python Java Ruby C
plus plus or PHP as a programming
language to develop a chatbot designing
and building NLP chatbots that accept
speech and Text data is made easier by
dialog flow you can go through many
projects to get the rough idea there are
many platforms which will help you to
build a chatbot regardless of how
excellent your chatbot is there is
always room for development the finest
chatbot developers constantly enhance
their Bots over the time using Ai and
machine learning social media
recommendation system the rise of web
services like Netflix Amazon and YouTube
has increased the use of recommender
systems in our daily lives they are
algorithms that insist users in finding
information that is pertinent to them
recommender systems are important in
some forms since they can generate a lot
of income or allow you to set yourself
apart from rivals in order to provide
recommendations it evaluates the
relationship between the user and the
object as well as the palace between
users and positions coming to predicting
stock this application is widely
applicable everywhere as AI career
aspirants one will love to develop stock
prediction applications as it is full of
data this project would be ideal for
students who want to work in the finance
industry because it it can provide I
repeat because it can provide them a
better understanding of very various
aspects of the field coming to medical
diagnosis this project is advantageous
from a medical standpoint AI projects
can be created to detect heart-based
diseases and also detect cancer it is
intended to offer patients with heart
illness online medical advice and
guidance after processing the data this
system will search the database for any
illnesses that might be connected to the
given details using data mining
techniques this intelligent system
determines the disease that the
patient's information most closely
resembles
based on the system diagnosis losers can
then speak with qualified medical
professionals users of the system can
also view information about various
doctors coming to an important project
that is search engine search engines are
utilized by all we look for information
on the greatest product to buy a nice
area to hang out or solutions to any
questions we have NLP is is quite
significant in modern search engines
because a lot of language processing
takes place there python is the widely
used language to develop any search
engine search engine is mainly confined
with lots and lots of data it is helpful
for any AI career as parents next is
virtual assistants here the challenge is
to build a virtual assistant to assist
user why do you need virtual assistant
in your devices when you are building
your own it is also interesting for a ml
developer to build a virtual assistant
it involves NLP and data mining voice
based virtual assistants are popular
today because they make life easier for
users NLP is utilized to comprehend
human language in order to construct
this system when a voice command is
received the system will translate it
into machine language and store the
commands in its database hate speech
detection in so social media automated
hate speech detection is a crucial
weapon in the fight against hate speech
propagation especially on social media
for the job many techniques have been
developed including a recent explosion
of deep learning based system
for the objective of detecting hate
speech a number of techniques have been
investigated including conventional
classifiers classifiers based on deep
learning and combination of both of them
on the other hand a number of data set
benchmarks including Twitter sentiment
analysis have been introduced and made
available for the evolution of the
performance of these algorithms and the
last one is predicting house price you
will need to estimate the sale price of
a brand new home in any place for this
assignment the data set for this project
includes information on the cost of
homes in various City neighborhoods the
UCI machine learning repository is the
place where you may find the data set
needed for This research you will also
receive other data set with information
on the age of the population the city's
crime rate and the location of
non-retail Enterprises in addition to
the pricing of various residences it's
an excellent project to test your
knowledge if you are a newbie finding a
suitable job in the field of machine
learning is becoming increasingly
difficult the ideal way to display your
machine learning skill is in the form of
portfolio of data science and machine
learning projects a solid portfolio of
projects will illustrate that you can
utilize those machine learning skills in
your profile as well projects like movie
recommendation system fake news
detection and many more are the best way
to improve your early programming skills
you may have the knowledge but putting
it to the use what is keep you
competitive here are 10 machine learning
projects that can increase your
portfolio and enable you to acquire a
job as a machine learning engineer at
number 10 we have loan approval
prediction system in this machine
learning project we will analyze and
make prediction about the loan approval
process of any person this is a
classification problem in which we must
determine whether or not the loan will
be approved a classification problem is
a predictive modeling problem that
predict a class label for a given
example of input data some
classification problem include spam
email cancer detection sentiment
analysis and many more you can check the
project link from the description box
below to understand classification
problem and how to build a loan
protection system at number nine we have
fake news detection system do you
believe in everything you read in social
media isn't it true that not all news is
true but how will you recognize fake
news ml is the answer you will able to
tell the difference between real and
fake news by practicing this project of
detecting face new this ml projects for
detecting fake news is concerned with
the fake news and the true news on our
data set we create our tfid vectorizer
with SQL the model is then fitted using
a passive aggressive classifier that has
been initialized finally the accuracy
score and the confusion Matrix indicate
how well our model performs the link for
the projects in the description box
below at number 8 we have personality
prediction system the idea is based on
determining an individual personality
using machine learning techniques a
person personality influences both as
personal and professional life nowadays
many companies are shortlisting
applicant based on their personality
which increases job efficiency because
the person is working on what he is good
at rather than what is compelled to do
in our study we attempted to combine
personality prediction system using
machine learning techniques such as SVD
name based and Logistics regression to
predict a personal personality and
talent prediction using phrase frequency
method this model or method allow users
to recognize their personality and
Technical abilities easily to learn
about more this project check the link
in the description box below at number
seven we have Parkinson disease system
Parkinson disease is a progressive
central nervous system element that
affects movement and cause tremors and
stiffness it comprises five stages and
affects more than one million worldwide
each other in this machine learning
project we will develop an svm model
using python modules scikit-learn numpy
and pandas and svm we will import the
data extract the features and label and
scale the features split the data set
design and sales model and calculate the
model accuracy and at the end we will
check the Parkinson's disease for the
individual to learn about more this
project check the link in the
description box below at number six we
have text to speech converter
application the machine learning domain
of audio is undoubtedly cutting as right
now the majority of the application
available today are the commercial the
community is building several audio
specific open source framework and
algorithm other text-to-speech apis are
available for this project we will
utilize pytt sx3 pydt access 3 is a
python text to speech conversion
liability it operates offline unlike
other libraries and is compatible with
python 2 and python 3. before API
various pre-trained models were
accessible in Python but changing the
voice of volume was often difficult it
also needed additional computational
power to learn more about this project
check the link in the description box
below at number 5 we have speech
recognition system speech recognition
often known as speech two types is the
capacity of a machine or programmed to
recognize and transfer word is spoken
allowed into readable text mlsp's
recognition uses algorithm that models
speech in terms of both language and
sound to extract the more important
parts of the speech such as words
sentences and acoustic modeling is used
to identify the finance and the
phonetics on the speech for this project
we will utilize pyts X3 pyts X3 is a
python text to speech conversion Library
it operates offline unlike other
libraries and is compatible with python
2 and python 3. to learn more about this
project check the link in the
description box below at number 4 we
have sentiment analysis sentiment
analysis also known as opinion mining is
a state forward process of determining
the author's feeling about attacks what
was the user intention when he or she
wrote something to determine what could
be personal information we employ a
variety of natural language processing
and text analysis technology we must
detect extract and quantify such
information from the text to enable
classification and data management
station in this project we will use the
Amazon customer review data set for the
sentiment analysis check the link in the
description box below at number 3 we
have image classification using CNN deep
learning is a booming field currently
most projects and problem statement use
deep learning is and any sort of work
many of you like myself would choose a
conventional neural network as a deep
learning technique for answering any
computer vision problem statement in
this project we will use CNN to develop
an image processing project and learn
about its capabilities and why it has
become so popular we will go over each
stage of creating our CNN model and our
first spectacular project we will use
the CFI 10 data set for image
conspiration in this project to learn
more about this project check the link
in the description box below at number 2
we have face recognition system
currently technology absolutely amazes
people with Incredible invention that
makes life easier and more comfortable
face recognition has shown to be the
least intrusive and fastest form of the
biometric verification over time this
project will use opencv and face
recognition libraries to create a phase
detection system opencv provides a
real-time computer vision tool library
and Hardware we can create amazing
real-time projects using opencv to learn
how to create face recognition system
for you check the link in the
description box below and last but not
the least we have movie recommendation
system almost everyone today use
technology to stream movies and
television show while figuring out what
to stream next can be Discerning
recommendations are often made based on
a viewer history and preferences this is
done through a machine learning and can
be a fun and the easy project for the
beginners new programmers can practice
by coding in either python or R and with
the data from the movie lens dataset
generated by the more than 6000 users to
learn how to create movie recommendation
system for yourself or for your loved
ones check the project in the
description box below so these were the
top 10 mL projects you can start your
career in machine learning thank you so
much for being here if you enjoyed this
video please subscribe to our YouTube
channel and give a like to this video
thank you and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign